looks like white's king is escaping any
kind of force trade that was there peter
because we did see the eval bar
seem to imply that there was a forcing
queen trade but not anymore
yeah but it wasn't trivial i mean i also
was you know i saw the evolution bar and
i was trying to to find that check here
but i was also not able to to spot it
somehow i felt like you know somewhere
this queen d6 check would have been the
the decisive move but
i i didn't see how i get there but it
was there right peter we saw this idea
that i was mentioning with queen g1
queen d4 and queen c5 it was just a
forcing trade maybe on the analysis
board if you just go back to that moment
with c1 we've got the live boat on
already
oh by the way it's happened again it's
anyway so the game is a wrap
uh he has i think he just watched oh my
god oh my god but this will hurt eric
badly i mean just when he got a chance
to you know he had real hopes to to
maybe survive this terrible position he
he blundered into this i think he just
missed that the queens can be traded
from d6